[Music]
Zimbabwe being welcomed by the family we
just find a barbecue invite everyone
over we've got about 60 people here so
have another great barbecue somebody
look at what's going on the boys they're
over there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Zambian we just thought we can't go to
Zambia and not go to the ball one when
we go to the airport guess she was
waiting for us these two people make
sure like boys into their home they left
us their car for the whole week machaca
Ganga said I know just the person
tetchy getting she went and within three
days
where's the passport
[Music]
[Music]
there's one particular person here today
and if it wasn't for this person most of
us would not be would not even exist
yeah big secure is the main reason what
we're here in Zimbabwe because he wanted
to see big secure room waiting to see
how he was doing and we're really really
happy to see that he's doing well and
he's walking
we pray for big secure every day so
we're really going to be here and thank
you big secure for all your support and
for being here was it fantastic even
without the beer yeah I'll see you soon
uncle so nice and now the house is
spotless
I'm understand brain it's wonderful when
a plan comes together